de la diplomatie russe sergueï lavrov
était nos yeux et nos oreilles en russie
depuis des mois les journaliste
cameraman et recherchiste de
radio-canada témoigner d'un climat de
plus en plus hostile ça fait parti d'un
environnement de sang à son comble
depuis l'invasion russe l'étau s'était
resserré en mars moscou avait adopté une
loi limitant la liberté de la presse
force amphibie si radio-canada à
suspendre ses activités en russie moscou
va maintenant plus loin possible le
diffuseur public canadien rim ne
critique aux coqs poules canards
sculpteur snes et les radios les chaînes
accessibles ici qu après 44 ans de
présence dans le pays le gouvernement
russe ordonne sans préavis la fermeture
du bureau de siby si radio-canada et
révoque les visas de ses journalistes
une mesure de représailles qui durera
tant que les chaîne russe russia today
seront interdites au canada le crtc
avait ordonné le retrait en mars ce
diplomate russe qualifie même le
diffuseur public canadien de portes
voire relayant une propagande anti russe
ayrton study propre entrée en jeu mais
un gouvernement étranger n'a ordonné la
fermeture d'un bureau de radio canada
radio canada cbc est une entreprise de
presse totalement indépendante du
gouvernement canadien on a démontré sa
depuis toujours et nous sommes encore
alors c'est extrêmement effectivement
chacun le public canadien est le plus
grand perdant quoi la correspondante de
radio canada en russie ça ne se remplace
pas la présence sur le terrain on
n'était pas des envoyés spéciaux à
réussir étaient des correspondants on
vivait là en s'imprégner de la culture
et on le paie
cette décision survient après des années
de relations diplomatiques de plus en
plus tendues entre ottawa et moscou le
premier ministre canadien n'est pas
étonné une grande surprise que c'est une
menace pour poutine qui dépend de la
désinformation la mésinformation pour
induire ses citoyens en erreur pour
essayer de justifier cette guerre il est
la décision de retirer les chaîne russia
today au canada a été prise de manière
indépendante assure le gouvernement
canadien c'est le crtc qui a consulté
tonnes de canadiens ont rendu une
décision de presque sept mille mots
là-dessus en russie c'est simplement
mais qui dit on m légendaire malgré ces
représailles la ministre des affaires
étrangères ne reviendrai pas en arrière
c'était une excellente décision de
bannir un agent de propagande du
gouvernement risque y est rt des efforts
diplomatiques permettrait-il de
renverser la décision de moscou
la ministre n'est pas très optimiste la
relation elle est très difficile avec le
gouvernement et les organismes de
défense de la liberté de la presse sont
inquiets c'est excessivement dangereux
et c'est important justement de rappeler
à la population que une démocratie ça
permet aux journalistes de pouvoir faire
leur travail même quand ça fait mal même
quand ça fait pas les affaires du poids
le sort des employés locaux de radio
canada en russie demeure incertain d'ici
là radio canada continuera de courir la
russie à distance et compte ouvrir un
autre bureau dans cette région du monde
j'ai une permission pour retourner en
russie et pour faire mes bagages et vidé
le bourg
à ce moment on peut espérer
en attendant ces représailles met en
sourdine une signature familière à
laquelle le public canadien s'était
attaché ici tamara altérer ce que
radio-canada à saint pétersbourg
radio-canada
ici louis blouin et radio canada ottawa